voulait dit on à piéger un ascenseur
dans un supermarché je suis tombé sur
deux clients
incroyable je vous jure ce ne sont pas
des comédiens ils venaient pour aller
dans un fast food dans ce supermarché et
et mais qui sont complètement ouf rocha
[Musique]
je serai avec carte imagine r n
abandonne pas balayer de l'artiste on se
met ça en fait bloqué des routes c'est
de nous quand on les a mais trois
séquences déjà web dans son papier mais
bonjour oui branchant on a parlé de
débloquer là vous vous rendiez ou s'il
vous plaît messieurs on m'avait offert
je fais pas pour un vous allez grossier
vous allez prendre du poids les mecs je
te des forces avant toute chose
j'aimerais avoir vos nom prénom à tous
les deux oloron la gueule
bon je m'appelle j'y vois là d'accord
très bien et l'autre personne brésil 2 1
n 2 n espère y est vous a fait brian
hilton c'est bien ça le cousin paris
s'il tonne
il ya la même chevelure
les séries je vais pas vous parler un
petit peu pour se détendre
d'accord je suis madame sérieuses
commencent et bien enlever tout ce que
vous pouvez enlever leur enlever tout ce
que vous pouvez enlever aux canards
enlevé de pub le pull mais alors ça vous
êtes sur la ba oui parce que c'est pour
des questions de poids s'il vous plaît
merci également le tan tan aussi on
n'est pas là pour ça pour des question
également de poids sur l'ascenseur parce
que plus le point vers le haut
plus l'ascension ne peut pas descendre
plus le droit vers un autre plus quoi
[ __ ] mais la cystinose
jour et nuit pour qui le sens des
doubles ou que vous tous parlent
quelle langue oui j'ai compris tout
compris
vous sentez vous sautez faut descendre
assez bas et nous y allons mettre au
banc vous voulez jouer sans la seule
ouais désintérêt interviews auxquelles
vous devez danser dans l'ascenseur il y
avait ainsi fait on dort et pourquoi
c'est quoi ce truc non vous danser après
bien lancer bientôt six mois mais si
c'est ce que là mais je sais qu'on
allait jamais ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
alors
allez vous vous trouviez tossée blau
débloqué et débloqué
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
j'ai gardé
est ce qu'il va nous refaire la petite
danse suis pas violent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
il est sûr et merci vous accueille son
élan mishima les lieux franchement
exceptionnel les deux heureusement je
suis là je suis fan
je suis fan et franchement c'est pas des
clients et norouet j'ai jamais vu des
mecs aussi heureux dans un ascenseur ils
sont exceptionnels pas je suis fan de
moi je suis comme un fou sur eux les
chéris bravo les gars clé